as you're doing that what was the
biggest pushback from the athletes first
because
you're building this marketplace right
you guys focus on the athlete's side you
go to them
and i've got to imagine like yeah i want
to feel i want my fans to feel that way
but like
who else is on right how much can i make
like all these normal questions what
were the the big obstacles there
yeah all of them uh and i would even go
one more uh
at the time any type of direct to
consumer monetization of fans was like
super weird right it's one thing and for
patreon to do it
and you're like a long tail podcaster or
musician and you have no other funds and
you know it's not that weird to ask your
your your followers to support you
but these are like athletes making
millions of dollars in that case
and you know they were worried about
their brand they were worried about
selling out they were worrying about
charging their fans for something like
this they were worried that nobody was
on it
you know is is cameo even gonna be the
one right like
you know early days of platforms there's
no gear like at some point you start
getting escape velocity but
you know there's seven other companies
that had tried this that never got any
traction
you know we found out later right so
there were there are people that have
been burned
you know uh probably the the one we were
hearing the most about at the time was
called enthusia which was uh tiki barber
i think was part of it so yeah these are
like serious
athletes and entrepreneurs teaming up
trying to do similar things
weren't able to do it i think steve aoki
had
founded one with like dan bilzerian you
know a few years before we got going
so people had tried it but what we had
pretty high conviction was
we really never set out to like build
something that lebron james would do
we really thought there was an
opportunity with cameo to
help people like you know my good friend
lance thomas on the new york knicks who
you know wasn't the superstar he wasn't
carmelo anthony
but he's like the beloved player that
gets out of the community
you know people love him huge
personality we really thought there was
an opportunity for
to serve those type of people versus
that said i'd be lying to you if i told
you we really found product market fit
with
you know backup quarterbacks you know or
practice caught
uh you know left tackles we found
product market fit one day
when devon walked uh down to our morning
meeting
and he goes hey stephen i think cody his
roommate cody ko
with three million youtubers at the time
and people like cody you know x vine
stars
would do really well on this and we put
cody in
uh on a cameo uh he made
he we actually needed we bought him a
cameo for a youtube video that he made
that went hyper viral
he decided to launch himself on the
platform he popped off
and other similar kind of dinosaurs
popped off
then that started the expansion into
reality tv
and comedians and today sports is still
probably we're
famous for for sports we kind of came up
as the new autograph
but as our business it might be 10 now
and
you know we've really found product
market fit for people that are huge
personalities or people that are really
funny
how did you grow the consumer side right
so it's kind of uh
sounds like you just went and did the
hard work of recruiting you know
personality after personality or athlete
after athlete
where do all of the users come and you
know how do you convince them to
actually pay for this stuff
well just like any time you're inventing
a new
completely new product right the best
way for
people to know what it is is to like
experience it or see it
and you know a couple interesting growth
dynamics that
that we benefit from number one um all
of our supply
unlike grubhub or uber or any other
marketplace you
you think about our supply can literally
market themselves right they have
they're famous they have instagram they
have twitter they have followings
and their fans are the most likely
people in the world to book them so that
was a big thing
like our supply can get its own demand
that's a really important concept of
cameo
secondly we always say that every cameo
is a commercial for the next one
so just like i was able to show athletes
once i had the first reaction video
don't you want to make people feel like
this the
the customer flywheel was i buy you a
cameo you shared a twitter you have 300
000 followers on twitter
they all see this roast that i get
michael rappaport roasting you
they're like what is that that's amazing
we had to we had the watermark there
people started learning then they go to
the site
cameo oh my god look at all these people
that are there so it's really
it's really the flywheel effect of
getting its own demand
and then the fact that every cameo is a
commercial for the next world
85 of them are gifts the vast majority
of cameos are shared on social
so that's the plywood